- Three years ago, I
went skydiving in Dubai.
Right, skydiving is a really interesting
confront with fear, right?
So I got to stand up, so
I got to stand up.
So, all your friends,
what happens is you go,
sorry, I dropped my pen.
So what happens is you
go out the night before
and you take a drink with your friends.
And somebody says, "hey, we
should go skydiving tomorrow!"
and you go, "Yeah, we'll
go skydiving, yeah!"
"Yeah" everybody goes, "Yeah!"
and you go home by
yourself you like, "Umm."
Right, you like, "Well,
they was drunk too."
"right, so, maybe they not, I mean"
"we don't have to go."
"We don't have to do it."
And then that night
you're laying in your bed
and you just keep, "Uhh, uhh"
and you're terrified.
You keep imagining over and over again
jumping out of an airplane and you can't
figure out why you would do that.
Right, and you're laying there
and you have the worst night's sleep
of your life but
you still have the hope that
your friends were drunk.
You wake up the next day and you go
down where you said you would meet
and everybody's there.
And you're like, "Ah, oh,
cool, cool, cool, cool."
Right, so you get in the van and
you don't know that your friends had
the same night that you had,
cause they're pretending like they didn't.
They're like, "Yeah, my
uncle's a Navy SEAL,"
"and hey, you know,
it's going to be great."
"I've been looking forward to this."
so you like, "Oh my God, oh my God!"
and your stomach is terrible,
you can't eat and everything.
But you don't want to be the only punk
who doesn't jump out of this airplane.
So you get there and then
you have this safety brief.
And the guys are telling you,
"Well, if the chute doesn't open"
"what's going to happen
is you're going to"
well, what what could happen that
the chute wouldn't open?
Right, so you do a thing and what you do
is your first jump
you're attached to a guy
who's going to walk you out.
So you go and you get there
and there's an airplane
and nobody's stopping,
everybody's still going.
So you get onto the airplane and
you're sitting there
and you know it's extra
because you're sitting on some dude's lap,
some stranger, you're sitting on his lap.
And you're trying to make small talk,
"Yeah, man."
"So you be jumpin' with
people all the time, huh?"
So, you know, and then
you got to make sure.
"You got kids, right, you
got people you need to see."
Right, you want to make sure he's serious.
And you get in there,
so everything's normal.
So you fly, you go up and you go up.
You go up to 14,000 feet and you notice
there's a light, it's red and it's yellow
and green, right.
So, right now the light's red,
and you think at some point
the light's going to go green.
And you don't know what's going to happen.
Right, and you wait and it goes yellow,
and the light goes green,
and somebody opens the door.
And in that moment you realize
that you've never been
in a friggin' airplane
with the door open.
Right, terror, I'm sorry I'm spitting.
I'm sorry, terror, terror, terror, terror!
Right, so you go and then
if you were smart you sat in the back
so you don't go first.
Right, and then people start
going out of the airplane.
And you go, and the guy walks you up
to the end of the thing.
And you're standing at
your toes are on the edge,
and you're looking out down to death.
And they say, "On three!"
And they say, "One, two!"
and he pushes you on two because
people grab on three, right.
- (laughing)
- Right, and you go, "Uhhhh!"
you fall out of the
airplane and in one second
you realize that it's the
most blissful experience
of your life, you're flying.
Right, it doesn't feel
like falling, right.
You're actually kind of held a little bit
by the wind and then you start,
you start falling, you're falling,
and there's zero fear.
You realize at the point of maximum danger
is the point of minimum fear.
It's bliss!
And you're flying, right,
and you're doing it and then
20 seconds, 25 seconds, 40 seconds,
and you have enough time to like,
"There's that building, that's how I like"
"Oh, you can see the ocean!"
Right, you start doing all of that,
and the lesson for me
is why were you scared
in your bed the night before?
What do you need that fear for?
Just don't go!
Why are you scared in your
bed 16 hours before you jump?
Why are you scared in the car?
Why could you not enjoy breakfast?
What did you need, fear is,
fear of what?
You're nowhere even near the airplane.
Everything up to the stepping out,
there's actually no reason to be scared.
It only just ruins your day.
You don't have to jump.
And then in that moment,
all of sudden when you
should be terrified,
is the most blissful
experience of your life.
And God placed the best things in life
on the other side of terror.
On the other side of your maximum fear
are all of the best things in life.
You know, so that was sorry.
Sorry, that was my experience
with skydiving and fear.
- So practically speaking.
- But I didn't like that take,
I'm going to do it again.
I can sell it better.
I can sell that better.
The confrontation with fear is an absolute
magical way of facing the things we have
to do in this life, you know.
Forget security, live for experience.